hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - I did I'm at the
main menu because I wanted to point out
something that I just noticed um as I've
been playing to the game's more of these
little pieces are showing up I know
they're pieces of the marker so I'm like
as you going through the game you're
piecing things together and then more of
the memories are coming and you're going
either more insane and then the markers
start showing so that does it something
I wanted to show it's really cool
nice touch I like this main menu because
it is it's a neural network it's in his
brain it's like the marker is forming in
his brain anyway so I've no doubt about
that anyway getting back into the action
see you see advises all engineers to
carry one with them at all times to
unlock a vegetable never mind
ok you just crashed through the giant
wall and I need to go down there to meet
lady she down there which go I don't
know she was down there I'm assuming
she's not out of here alive one of us is
it's too dangerous for you to stay here
Ellie what are you talking about
just get your ass in here I'm starting a
system check now Oh am I gonna be the
hero or something like that brighter
whew oh yeah hard Oh lots of goodies
think gearing me up for something
actually what are they not gearing you
up for something what the hell oh the
wrong way what was I supposed to go
either way
I don't know apparently I'm gonna we'll
leave her behind notes oh here
Oh security gun ship docking bay that
should have been obvious but then again
I'm kind of an idiot Oh in here oh okay
Kelly yeah life support comms hey
gotta be rescued you I need you to be
rescued I couldn't save Nicole
but I can save you really
so uh
by that's really sad that's like crazy
sad why why did he do that because he
feels use the need to destroy the marker
are you ready to talk now oh why
so I can let you go - I can't do that
Nicole she's not real I never wanted to
let you go I still know dress her a lot
happened that we never wanted
Isak
touch me
I don't think that's a good idea either
please yeah thank you so ha ha ha no no
he's had that before yeah can't lady
screw you you're not real not real
oh hello its protection counterfeited
India no 200 armed security personnel
everything discovered even if you do
give him you won't get yeah we'll see
about that
nothing to stop me yet so I don't assume
that you will that was like really sad I
guess I guess Isaac's not like buying
into Nicole's thing the whole make us
whole so he's not like going real insane
he's still he's still holding his own
which is I need lots of plasma energy I
used look a ton just trying to get
through to the other place I mean
flamethrower ammo in
real cheap steps not do I have to I have
25 slots and ever since I got this
student so which is awesome I don't
think there's another suit yet until I
play like someone said a New Game+
you'll get new suits but I don't think
I'll be doing that unless I play like a
New Game+ on them I actually tried to do
cardboard boat but given how many times
I died in this one I don't think I'd be
able to make it through with just three
saves maybe maybe if I was like really
maybe I do like a live stream of it I
just go as far as I can on one life
would you like that
I mean bright in the comments if that's
something that you'd be interested in
just a live stream of hardcore me just
trying to get through ah you're not
going for me what the hell
uh hey buddy where you going
bill dude I don't know where that is
so if you could like articulate oh ah
what the hell
No slow down
that one there we should your head
forget
laughs Wow holy hell
I see that
give that oh yes there we go gosh you
know these things could
whoa there's like a whole hell of line
take that I missed
sorry Vader I'm mister
and this again about a my dancers very I
know baby - tons of items - the way I'm
liking what oh no the bodies are
disappearing yeah man it's like I don't
know why it must be something for design
for consoles they can't handle that many
free moving corpses I mean all the
corpses of rag dolls basically so each
or an independent physical object
oh peridot hello thank you very much so
I would assume it eats up a lot of
resources to have especially with like
the little the little kids zombies I
would imagine that yeah I would become
tough oh hello zone one four one six
five one four six oh for hacking Lee
epic
well I know stay there and then I'm
gonna come over
stop your face thank you
oh my god there's no - actually you I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna leave the door
gonna close behind yourself yeah there
we go okay see perfect now is easy oh
hello
those people with shields
there's shields I don't know how to do
that uh in here no you said open fire
I'm not gonna stop I'm in the bathroom
maybe dead why would I be dead
you didn't even shoot at me oh no you
don't have a way boy what am I gonna do
oh hello
I must say that like dead space it's not
the scariest game I've ever played
obviously amnesia is scary but the story
is great you know it's so immersive I
love it
oh hello loose oh hello guys can you see
me in there no you're blind bat alright
um still no Waypoint
oh here we go stairs can you see me
mm-hmm lots of goodies like tons tons of
goodies I'm not even close to full up oh
that's because I spent a lot of plasma
yeah well not actually pretty I'm
actually pretty impressed at how I
handled that Mitchell part with all
those little guys cuz III only got hit
once nose by spitter bases are not
called spinners
that's lever dad whatever you called
oh hello
whoa whoa what is that
whoops ah holy hell
oops my bad guys oh my god did you see
how many of them holy [ __ ] oh it's dark
it's like really dark oh my god oh no no
no no no no no no no no stop it stop it
aw come on burn you [ __ ]
ah we did come from
Oh another one
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hold on little buddy nope
nope I got one ah what I had like so
much help
amen I should have switched weapons
stupid reload oh man like oh so many of
them can I can I put it back in now and
put it back in
no my god oh okay
okay just use I don't even think that my
yeah oh I should have used this thing
open the door get it on the floor
everybody do the dinosaur
there we go
this is effective that's seriously that
stasis like my jet that stasis thing it
gets cool to ever
that was an exploding guy right they all
dead out there still see the little
squirmy is going to run up if any I
wasn't a flop i won Oh next to coming
after me reload come on
there we go
that's okay alright now that I get that
care of I can go this way was that a
metal detector I wonder what would
happen if I go through the work yeah oh
that uh uh I'll say it was gonna be like
left for dead you go through the metal
ticker Brandt boy all the zombies in the
area get away fit to your position but
no oh
something down there it's man these guys
did not put up a fight how can i Isaac
by himself just rock everything still no
way for well hi lady you back off
that's why I'm here rise o to show you
the way
ah okay mine does not do that oh thank
you lady give me objective totally weird
that now you're invading my technology
but whatever it's all good it's all good
lady perfectly normal perfectly normal
okay I'm not going in the door she said
oh there to do everybody
I'm going home this guy yes that was it
really does I need to walk through with
this guy hey was it Lawrence I don't
care I know buddy a lot huh don't trust
ya whoops ah come on what the hell
really the audio is that it research
room is 43 509 I can't stop thinking
about the formulas from patient force
last session I'm so clearly ordered to
keep playing back in my mind final
configuration example enraged I can
almost solve it myself
it's funny I was telling Travis the
other day that it's almost like it wants
us to succeed I've never seen anything
like oh [ __ ] that's what they're doing
how many markers are they making
I like the skeleton do a marker whoa
Division of microbiology and infectious
diseases that does not sound good I
guess another one think about this is
infection right it is an alien life-form
weird I guess the marker if it wants you
to succeed that's its way of reproducing
I don't know
interesting stuff anyway that's all the
time I got for this episode thank you
everyone so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next part but
I